now in order to update the CX and CY
offsets for trim sprites we have to do a
couple of interesting things first off
you need to understand that texture
Packer will only do a smart trim from
the edges to the center so for instance
if you end up in a situation where
you've got a nice box and pixels in the
top-left quadrant it won't actually trim
that sprite because it can't shrink it
to the center because of this we don't
actually need any of the information
from the frame in order to create the
new CX and CY values instead all we have
to do is figure out the half dimensions
for the sprite and create an inverse of
that which represents our offset now we
store the CX and CY here which means if
the sprite is or is not trimmed it
doesn't really matter in the drawing
function that uses these values later